if your grown-ass boyfriend he's making
you happy but he was still getting
financial assistance from his parents
would that turn you off
yes okay that would turn you off you'd
say like dude get it together like you
you're a successful woman latina living
limitless you're paying your own rent
it's not even your own mortgage but dude
let's say he's your age you know mid to
late twenties get it together get it
together it'd be a turn off yeah okay
nancy turn off if dude still
like you you pay your own rent you you
live with your dog mr meatball follow mr
meatball on on instagram what's his name
but like if you're doing your own thing
like you came up you left dallas you
picked up your stuff you you know i
think you broke up with your boyfriend i
don't want to put your business out
there you came solo status
very confidently yeah okay
um
what are your thoughts on that
yeah i
like it goes back into like does money
bother you and the spouse and like i
just wouldn't want a guy that was more
broke than me
and then that puts all the pressure on
you and then that's where the fights and
resentments comes out of like who's
paying more like and i hate the idea of
like just
taking care of somebody
it's a major turn off for you yeah okay
i agree with that i just want to add one
thing yeah go go this is your show my my
thing is
some i think that there are some men who
are not financially stable they didn't
come from money and they don't know how
to maybe generate it but i do think some
of those men can be ambitious and hungry
and want to learn so i think sometimes
maybe successful women can get those men
if they're willing
to have ambitious and push forward and
teach them the ropes
do you know what you're doing you hit a
um
a word that we'll touch on i hear ladies
say all the time
okay i don't care if they're broke
but do they have ambition
ambition is a turn on like meaning like
yeah i'm broke right now but i'm telling
you baby if i stick with this thing i
i'm gonna do i'm gonna figure this out i
got this yes is that what it is yes okay
so you might be broke today but you're
not gonna like that ambition that drives
like we could build together we're gonna
build this house together y'all know oh
i feel like i'm in church right now
nancy is ambition a turn on yeah for
sure the only thing is is like if he has
a plan and then are you part of
his plan to help like financially stable
him while he's figuring out his oh
good caveat it's like well baby we're
going to build this thing together i get
ambition but in the meantime can you
make my car payment for me please
[Music]